[Music]
afternoon thank you for coming you've
arrived at after Darwin to what extent
is the theory of natural selection
somehow a relic is it too narrow and
about to be replaced by a new science of
that includes cultural evolution or does
the promise paradigm shift not really
challenge Darwin's theory Terrace answer
that I've got designer clay
she's a comparative and developmental
psychologist with expertise in
primatology which means she studies
chimps and bonobos and bonobos right
with a real focus on empathy language
and social learning in the animals in
Amazon in children
excellent um on my left we have Massimo
Pigliucci he's a professor of philosophy
at CUNY which is City College in New
York he's one of the leading advocates
of the extended evolutionary synthesis
which he will no doubt tell us about a
new way of thinking about an
understanding evolutionary phenomena to
his left we have Tim luhan's who's a
professor of philosophy of science at
Cambridge and he's investigator on the
large multi institution project putting
the extended evolutionary synthesis to
the test Tim do you want to start can
our current theories capture the full
richness of evolution so it would be
nuts to say that our full our current
theories can capture the full richness
of evolution that would be an example of
the worst kind of scientific hubris just
like those physicists who thought that
physics was over at the end of the 19th
century and then got bashed by
relativity theory and quantum mechanics
there are however some really
interesting developments going on in
evolutionary biology right now there's
extremely interesting attention not just
to genes but to the mushy insides of
organisms and the difference that that
makes to adaptation
there's extremely interesting work such
as the work that Zanna does for example
on cultural evolution a realization that
differences between organisms including
adaptive differences between organisms
or
and explained by what they learn rather
than by the genes that they pass on that
said a lot of that work doesn't really
challenge evolutionary theory all that
much it seems to me in fact in some ways
some of that work is extremely
conservative with respects of the
current models all those sort of more
traditional models that we have so a lot
of work in cultural evolution for
example yes it talks about the
interesting ways in which animals learn
from each other but when you ask where
do those learning dispositions come from
in the first place the answer is it's
just more natural selection acting on
genetic variation and some of the really
radical views in these areas also credit
learning with an active role in shaping
how we learn as well as just what we
learn evolution is it's a moving target
we shouldn't think that what's going on
right now is this kind of key moment of
revolution Darwin's theory itself that
changed in all kinds of ways compared
with what we have now but yes there are
interesting things happening right now
but no revolution it seems to me okay
Massimo what do you think can our
current theories capture the full
richness of evolution oh I take the
current theories to means kind of the
gene-centred approach right no wait no
so no they don't and for the same
reasons we just heard there is no
scientific theory we really know none at
the moment at least not in the history
of science has ever captured everything
you know that's doing modern fundamental
physics just just as as much as it was
at the end of the 19th century and it's
certainly true in biology what I do
think is that one of the things that is
characterized by ology so far this could
change but unlike other fields such as
physics there hasn't been any complete
overturn of essentially their winning
ideas you know we got the evolution
biology started with Darwin essentially
and what Darwin said still goes more
complex more mechanisms more phenomena
lots of stuff that Darwin obviously did
not know or could not know about but the
foundations are still the same as
opposed to say in physics where you know
internal mechanics is out the window
when once that general relativity came
in it's used now only for
practical purposes because gives good
approximation but the picture of the
university that uterine mechanics gives
us is in fact wrong and it's been
abandoned nothing like that yeah has
happened in biology now this could be
because biology is a field that is
younger than physics in that respect or
it may be because that one really did
get something fundamental right and
we're just building but there's a slight
difference in saying he was he he was
right but did he capture all of that
there is no right is some of the stuff
that he might have not have been aware
of trivial or important I think it's
important marvelous there is something
to talk about I'm sure you're glad
[Laughter]
right yeah I mean to be honest we I
think we all agree ampere that I think
that we shouldn't ever assume any theory
can explain everything particularly in
the complex well we live in and the fact
that the more stuff we study in terms of
evolution and other aspects of biology
the more we realize there's more and
more questions that need to be answered
and so I think it would be a bad
scientist to assume that we have all the
answers well I do think though is that
while there's a lot of richness that we
still need to understand I think to me
the Darwinian principle of natural
selection does go a it seems to be going
a very long way to explain some of the
ultimate principles of evolution that
we're still continuing to see and what I
sort of feel as an empirical researcher
is that we've got this really strong
basis that I don't feel that there's any
strong evidence yet to suggest that we
should move away from or abandoned I
think nobody in evolutionary research is
arguing that we should abandon Darwin
maybe people's view of evolution is a
little bit oversimplified and the
theories that we're now using to
understand the evolution have massively
expanded since Darwin there's a huge
expanse in our understanding and it's an
evolution if there is movie and all
sorts of interesting directions but I do
think that there are some things like
for example the cultural lives of
animals which is something I study it's
not something that was ever really truly
appreciated how
fairly important that might be in shape
and behavior so I do think we need to
expand theories but I don't find so far
maybe we can discuss that whether we
need to abandon what we've built so far
rather than expand our our appreciation
of these these other effects that
perhaps weren't explained when for
example the modern synthesis of
evolution was first developed right but
when you study you mentioned the
cultural evolution or empathy yeah I
sort of very reductionistic version of
that said well there must be a gene for
empathy or but do they inherit would say
that no but it's often can't work ok I
disagree with those fantasies I'm not
gonna miss sunny negates but I mean I
think which are dark it's exciting news
well I do have a problem with kind of
reductionism to that extent and my
genetic determinism I don't think that's
what most people in the field are
debating ok but yeah that's fine but it
is I suppose that ghost of Richard
Dawkins there is a PR crisis and that's
maybe what we're here to discuss that
there is that - fierce reductionism that
says look if it unless there's a gene
for it it does just doesn't think anyone
seriously and studying these processes
knows that like it's it it like - that
Jessica village doesn't even work in
this way and we'd like to let ik
theories of evolution I mean this is
areas of Tim and mass we can develop on
would never ask would never dismiss the
role that the environment and
development play I think on on shaping
these behaviors at least to my knowledge
and and that's why someone like myself I
study both proximate mechanisms of say
how children learn from their
environment and how they transmit
culture as well as these ultimate
questions about why we have culture ok
we're probably gonna be more the
ultimate question ok I disagree a little
bit yet on the degree can I get in the
disagreement queue as well yes all right
thank you take a number great so I guess
my take is I wish that the field was
quite that as you you've been describing
but you know I remember
being very until fairly recently before
I moved full-time to philosophy into a
one of the most prestigious evolution
departments in the country in the United
States and having to fight really hard
with some of my colleagues for them to
admit that things like development
phenotypic plasticity behavioral
plasticity and so on sports are not just
minor annoyances that need to be
accounted for but are major players I
come from I'm lucky in a way like come
from a field of comparative and
developmental so I'm sort of very much
slap-bang it's built-in right the
difference is you spend a lot of time
with animals and he spends a lot of time
with academic Jim did you want I want to
be even-handed by disagreeing with
Massimo and Zhanna
so they both portrayed this image of a
fairly static evolutionary theory
whereby Darwin says a bunch of things
and then there's a sort of broad
inheritance up until maybe a few years
ago and Massimo saying that's a bit
weird right do we really think Darwin's
right about everything and zan is kind
of saying well maybe Darwin's really
onto something that's why the ideas have
persisted for so long it's really
important I think to understand that
Darwin is in many ways quite different I
think to the theory that we have now so
the podcast talks debates courses and
articles visit the Institute's of art
and ideas click the link on-screen now -
ie
TV